do you mess around with nfts at all i uh
was very very early to nfts um and uh
it's not very popular uh in some sectors
of this industry specifically with
bitcoin maximals etc
and it's why i make such a serious
delineation between monetary maximalism
and then like the technology competition
but in
may of 2020
or so um i started to
hear about it look at it it was
interesting to me etc um and the more
that i dug into it i realized i was like
this is the same argument as to bitcoin
versus gold right
the digital version of something is
always bigger than the analog version
right so the physical version is that
just your gut says or is there
name one asset that you can think of
where the physical version is not bigger
than the digital version i can't and you
have just put words to something that i
feel
but have never had words that feels so
true to me that's why i'm so hyped about
bitcoin and ethereum and nfts is like
dude the my brain switched over to
digital so fast on artwork i can't tell
you so
there was actually i found myself
somebody wanted to um
send me something and they were like oh
you know i want to send you i forget
what it was a painting or something like
that and i in my heart was like oh man
if it was an nft i would [ __ ] love it
but i'm like the physical thing thank
you that's so sweet as oh my god so kind
but you know go ahead and keep it it's
weird how fast that happened the the
thing um
if you just go down the line so the easy
examples are shopping you know uh all
that type of stuff taxis
uber the reason why most investors
missed uber as an investment opportunity
is they compared uber to the total
addressable market of the taxi industry
well that was actually the wrong
analysis that's really interesting
because the digital version of taxis
ended up actually not owning any cars
and it was a market expanding technology
because it didn't just eat taxis it
didn't just eat black cars there are
millions of people in the united states
who are young who don't own a car and
they uber everywhere how many people in
manhattan own a car
well most of the young people they just
uber everywhere or they use public
transportation right and so what ends up
happening is the
opportunity or the addressable market
expanded drastically
with a digital version of the analog
if you look at gold goldmark caps about
10 trillion bitcoin today is 1 trillion
i fully believe that bitcoin is not only
going to drastically eclipse gold's
market cap but it'll be a market
expanding technology if you ask me right
now how to go buy gold i couldn't tell
you agreed i'd have to call a broker or
go on a website or you know have to
figure it out i don't know how to do
that
myself and most digital natives know
exactly how to buy bitcoin
and so
you look at that now bring it to art
the art market you know depending on how
you count or whatever trillion dollars
or less right
the digital art market you just said it
open seeded three billion dollars in
transaction volume you know in a single
month crazy
and so why is
bitcoin
better as a global store value than gold
why is the digital version better than
the analog well one
there is a digital component to it
meaning that anyone in the world with an
internet connection can sign in and
immediately start to transact in it so
there's an accessibility advantage
two is there's fractionalization i don't
have to buy a full bitcoin at 45 50 000
i can buy a piece of a bitcoin
uh three is that i can carry it around
really simply on my phone right or on my
laptop rather than lugging around
physical goals there's a portability
advantage to it and then you start to
look at it from
a storage cost etc right there's a whole
bunch of advantages digital version
versus the physical version
what happens with the digital art it's
the same thing
more accessible more divisible more
portable all this type of stuff and so
if we're going to go and move our lives
into this like metaverse digital world
whatever you know is the the new way to
describe it
why would we leave
the assets we care about in the analog
world no we're going to bring them into
the digital world too all right i'm
going to try to touch on something
ephemeral to just drive this point home
have you ever looked at a vv vault
vv vault no
this is so crazy so
vivi is a collectibles company that's
partnered with like dc marvel
but their their nfts look like actual
collectibles so it looks like a toy it
looks like a statue like it it's they're
going out of their way to sort of
literally just digitize the collectibles
industry but they're brilliant to move
and i'm still dazzled by this is that
they gave their users the ability to
create these it they've made it right
now i'm sure future iterations won't but
it looks like a vault so you're going
through a vault door and then you're on
the inside but it's just a virtual space
for you to put display all the things
you've collected
the level of creativity that people show
in placing their items is insane so i'll
give you one example
the
the way that they have programmed this
space so one of the collectibles you can
buy is the delorean from back to the
future
and one guy put it upside down and on
the roof so it's actually outside the
vault but it plays an animation in the
loop of the flux capacitor turning on
which has all this electricity right if
you remember the movie all the
electricity sparks and then it
disappears so it does that animation so
as you walk through this guy's vault
every 30 seconds whatever all this
electricity just runs around the ceiling
because he's placed his collectible and
i was like oh my god
if i have the physical thing you one you
have to come into my house to see the
physical collectible b it's not gonna
have electricity sparking everywhere
it's gonna zap some kid walking by so
not only now am i only bridled by my
imagination but anyone anywhere can come
and see this and so now as a social
creature that wants to connect with my
community
and i'm given these virtual tools i
don't need to be wealthy right you no
longer need a big crazy house to display
all of this art
you can create this virtual thing put
all your stuff in a way that only you
have done it takes time right you talk
about money is this equation to time so
we know we value time so when i see
somebody who spent their time creating
something like this i'm just like oh my
god like this is so much cooler than
what collectibles have ever been ever
before in history and so i started
thinking about all right now you're
gonna have companies that spring up that
are making virtual galleries where the
gallery itself is like this crazy
physics-defying piece of art you're not
just walking through a mimicry of a
traditional gallery you're on the
[ __ ] moon you're in outer space
you're inside the body whatever you want
like it is
the creativity that the digital realm
unleashes
because you you no longer have to obey
the laws of physics
it's just oh my god
i think there's an element of like you
don't have to obey the laws of physics
you also don't have to ask permission
of anybody
right so you know um if you go and you
look at an art gallery in manhattan for
example
how many people really got an
opportunity to design the art gallery
well they're usually people who have
some sort of pedigree they got trained
somewhere right there's like all these
like hurdles to get in and so it ends up
being a lot of the same people who all
know each other and they're the ones who
do it
on the internet imagine if you held a
global competition for whoever could
create the best art gallery
right and there was like a prize for it
you'd get some really really cool stuff
because there was no barriers to become
the person who could do that
that's all this is is it's now just
saying but you don't have to come do it
in manhattan like just do it on the
internet and i think that um
you know the best analogy i have for
this is think of twitter if i said to
you tom you know what you're going to do
every day you're going to go hang out in
this virtual reality
square and you're going to talk to
random strangers you'd be like dude that
sounds like cool to like test one time
but like i got things to do but what do
you do you go through the portal which
is your computer or your phone and you
go and you hang out in a digital
square
and you talk to strangers
like that is in some weird way a version
of virtual reality right i tweeted
recently i said we live in virtual
reality already
it doesn't look like the thing that you
put you know the oculus headset on and
you walk around you can touch and feel
things and like like that's like level
you know two three four five of virtual
reality
but twitter
created virtual reality for people and
you can go there and you know hey every
day we all come here and meet up again
right and you keep going and then what
am i basically doing i'm basically
walking around the square and i'm saying
okay tom's talking about this this
person talking about this this person
about this and i have a choice do i want
to button the conversation do i want to
reply do i want to quote tweet do you
want to say hey tom just said whatever
and i go to tell my friends i have to
retweet button like like you start to
think through this and it's like
yeah this is all gonna happen how
quickly does that happen up for debate
uh what technologies is it built on up
for debate um how
how should an investor invest up for
debate how should you as a market
participant who's not an investor wants
to be a user how should you use this
stuff up for debate
but i think that
one of the trends that every great
investor has figured out or one of the
activities
is just find that kind of
direction that the world is moving as be
an observer understand the world's
moving this way and then go and say okay
well what are people using to your point
about observing it to not judge it so
one of the things the nft market has
taught me is that
in fact i wrote my rules they were
tongue-in-cheek when i wrote them but i
think i should publish them
is that
everything you think is cool is gonna go
to zero and everything that you think is
dumb is gonna moon
and i've just seen that play out over
and over and over again it's really hard
to predict what other people are going
to think is cool because it's really a
moment is created energy is orchestrated
somehow through this it's not an
invisible hand because there are some
people that are really good at it but
they can get the energy moving towards a
project for whatever reason like i don't
know if you paid attention what happened
with loot
so um the guy that i consider my king of
alpha david
um he
sent me a tweet like i was about to go
to bed and he was like hey tom this
thing called lou just popping off look
at it i looked at it and i'm like this
is white words on black a black
background this doesn't make any sense
and i was like but i know this industry
and if people believe that this is like
new fresh exciting that at least for a
moment there's going to be this influx
of attention now that moment could be 10
years that moment could be 10 minutes i
have no idea but i'm getting better and
better at sort of arbitraging some of
these things so i bought two of them and
then a couple days later if you owned
them you got an airdrop of uh basically
their token
and i didn't even know about the airdrop
and the same guy david was like hey tom
because you bought two you've been
airdropped this stuff you actually have
to go pull it out of the contract
directly and so i'll show you how to do
it so here you go into ether scan and
this is how you do it
and i got it and i got my two bags of
gold and
as of that day
that thing so i bought the ones that i
bought i think i bought it i can't
remember if it's 1.9
eth for the original loots
or 0.9 but it was in there somewhere and
at the time i got the gold which
remember i didn't even know existed i
was already making money hand over fist
just on the actual squares that i bought
and
the bags of um their coin that my friend
had to tell me were there i went and
sold one of the two
for fifty thousand dollars
and i was like i imagine if a friend was
like hey dude i know you don't know but
in your bread box in the back cupboard a
guy just left you 50 grand you'd be like
what just happened
it was so
surreal and i was just like okay
don't think about things
think about the nature of things and i
was like this is telling me something
about the nature of humans of creative
energy of attention and how it can be
swayed about enthusiasm and how it it
moves sort of restlessly it never lands
on one thing and stays and so there's
these really predictable curves that
these projects go through and i'm like
hold on
if you do your you know
ten thousand twenty thousand thirty
thousand hours of research and you'd
like really figure this game out
obviously never invest a single dime
over what you're prepared to lose
because nfts are the single highest risk
investment i've ever seen humanity come
up with i want to make that really
[ __ ] clear
but it is
so interesting to see how it captures
that same part of the psyche around
sports betting
how we're all locked up because of
what's going on with kovid like there's
all these factors that have come into
play and just that crypto's taking off
and nfts have answered the question of
whether there's a real thing there and
whether people will value them but once
i stopped judging the market and just
started saying this is happening
whether i think it should or not whether
i think white text on the black
background should be cool or not
it is and it's capturing energy
and
dude it wasn't long ago that i made 50
000 a year
so i was like this is so crazy and this
comes back to like my obsession people
need to do their own research i cannot
predict the future you cannot predict
the future who knows this could all go
to nothing tomorrow
that does not seem likely and given
what's going on today the nature of the
technology right understand it think
from first principles and it becomes far
easier to do novel things but just
looking at what's going on i
legitimately want to with all the
caveats of you have to be so careful you
cannot go blindly into this
but i can think of few things that are
worth people's time and energy to
understand more than the blockchain and
that if this were a baseball game we are
still in the locker room getting ready
to come out onto the field
it's like because i mean that from a
technology standpoint like even forget
just that you could buy bitcoin or
ethereum or whatever today and it will
go up in value
what's going to be built on the back of
the technology will create a world that
will be as unrecognizable as a
post-internet world would have been to
me in you know 93 before i'd even heard
of email to now i mean that's utterly
just it's a transformation that i could
never predicted
it's gonna be the same thing but this
one's happening in full view because we
already have the internet so it's
already you and i are talking right now
to you know hopefully millions of people
and then on top of that
it's
we've all seen it happen before so you
can say hey guys remember mobile phones
hey guys remember the internet this is a
big one like that
and so i think this is going to be
i'm going to make a statement and you're
going to say whether i'm a fool or not i
think this will be the biggest wealth
transfer ever that we've ever seen like
robber baron moment type wealth transfer
but it it's not going to go to a really
really small number of people it's going
to go to whoever the [ __ ]
takes the time to learn about this and
go there's some percent percentage of my
daily income doesn't like it will go to
people who don't even think in net worth
terms yet
because this is as raoul paul said this
is the first time in human history where
the average person has been able to
front run the institutions so this is a
chance for people to get ten dollars
every paycheck whatever but like to get
in and now whether it just becomes sort
of wealth redistributed because so many
like the older and more established your
wealth the less likely you are to move
on this quickly
well you you got to think too um
from an investing standpoint you've got
to ask yourself like
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]